foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where debt is dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work they love to create
actual amazing relationships Dr John
deloney Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author and host of the Dr
John baloney show is my co-host today
as we answer your questions at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five so John it's a little bit
distracting that as we go on the air
Rachel Cruz is outside taking pictures
and drawing a crowd oh she's she is way
more engaging than we are yes two old
boring guys and you have like a
brilliant wonderful person out there yes
it's embarrassing but such it is well
come visit the lobby at Ramsey Solutions
if you ever get a minute because you
just never know who's gonna walk through
that's the moral of that story all right
let's start this hour off with George in
Charlotte North Carolina hey George how
are you
hey guys good afternoon thank you so
much for taking my call sure man what's
up
so I put myself in the
um definitely very embarrassed about it
but um basically had a 2013 Buick Verano
which uh was driving for work and
personal and it ended up needing a new
motor
um it was paid off so I traded it in and
got two thousand dollars for it and you
know I wanted to I knew I didn't want to
take out another car Alone
um but I ended up going to a Toyota
dealership because we didn't have much
cash to buy something you know from a
friend and so look around the 2016
Toyota Corolla for 15.5 bought the uh
the loan total loan came out to 17. and
so um we got it two days later it
stopped I was at the dealership for
another issue and the check engine light
was on went back to the car uh car
didn't turn on
obviously we were upset I was upset and
scared because of my so many issues in
my previous vehicle
um they were trying to sell us for a car
which was you know kind of overpriced
and what they sell it for online and so
we kind of just left the dealership my
friend told me that I can just cancel
that loan and get a different car and I
foolishly went on the weekend to get a
different car much more expensive uh
2020 Toyota Camry for 26k and now I have
two loans
um and I'm in communication with the
first uh Toyota dealership but they have
no legal obligations to let me out and
uh I'm just trying to see what the best
solution is how old are you
I'm 32.
how do you
where'd you get the idea that your
friend was not a brainless idiot
oh your friend and ask about a fifteen
thousand dollar loan your friend is not
a lawyer or a judge is he an Alabama fan
too oh I'm just kidding that was a
dealer dig
oh my gosh George
yeah he uh well he purchased his cards
and uh sells them you know overseas and
so I kind of was you know he said he
does all the time he buys some
dealerships all the time and so
I mean I'm not even putting the blame on
him I made the decision at the end of
the day and you know I'm just trying to
think how can yeah I'm just saying the
process you use to make the bad decision
was a bad process thus it led to a bad
decision like you took advice from an
idiot okay
um
wow
and then you upgraded your mistake
you were like man I made a tough
decision hold my own beer yeah I can I
can do another one man so now you have
40 000 in car debt because your old car
that was two thousand dollars broke
that's the end of the story and what do
you guys make
I worry about my wife is part-time she's
in school right now and so I think she's
making around 10 and I make forty eight
five
okay so you have to sell both vehicles
sir that's what I want to do and I don't
see the loss and I'm just trying to
figure out what the best way to do it I
went I met with the manager from the
first vehicle the 2016 Toyota and you
know just you know kind of let them know
hey you know there was a few issues with
purchasing that vehicle I mean after the
purchase such as like I said check
engine light car doesn't stop I mean I
was at the dealership that didn't start
right in front of the dealership and
then the sales agent
um you know stopped working the other
day after for some reason so I mean I
feel like I have a few
kind of grievances that I can
um bring to the table to try to get out
of this thing and I'm supposed to meet
with the general manager to like maybe
this week what the GM's probably going
to do is offer to fix the car and
they're going to do just enough to get
that light off and say yeah go about
your way right so yeah and then you're
selling it and then you sell the other
one and you get your two thousand dollar
car the same weekend by the way it's a
Camry and a Corolla like it's not like
these are dream cars you just uh yeah
you got scared man so have a buddy that
you call reach out to and let's pause
this Behavior so we can start catching
ourselves before we do something dumb
again when I did one like this a guy
gave me a scripture and I'll give it to
you
Proverbs says he who is impulsive
exalts folly and my friend explained to
me that the word Folly is a verb that
means a fool in action
when you are impulsive you are a fool in
action when I am impulsive I am a fool
in action and that's what got you here
my brother and so you're gonna you're
gonna write some stupid texts I'm sorry
you're going through this and we'll help
you any way we can
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we were drawn to Christian Healthcare
Ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
Health Care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the Better Business Bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
foreign
[Music]
personality number one best-selling
author is my co-host today as we take
your calls about your life and your
money around here we're fired up and
wired up to come to work every day
because we're on a mission
to give people hope to give people
freedom but we only get to do that
because of another kind of freedom and
that's the kind we get to enjoy because
of our military
our servicemen and service women we love
you guys so if you're listening today
and you're a veteran
thank you
thank you for your service
thank you for your sacrifice
and for Veterans Day we want to honor
you so this is going to go really really
fast
get ready
today only
we're going to put 1 000 veterans
through Financial Peace University free
salute
thank you
if you're a veteran go to
ramseysolutions.com Veterans you'll fill
out one simple form and our team will
reach out to you to verify and get you
set up you've served our country now
it's our turn and our honor to serve you
and again we'll run this until midnight
tonight or for the first 1 000 veterans
right now go to ramseysolutions.com
veterans
get Financial Peace University for free
if you're from one of the first one
thousand
to get there and do that and it will end
at midnight tonight that's fun very cool
yeah and here's what's really fun it's
so needed yeah I mean the Thousand will
be gone and really fast yeah uh I I I've
always just been stunned
um the folks that I've worked with in
the military communities and my friends
how preyed upon they are oh yeah by all
different sort of financial this is and
that's and schools and
for-profit Universe just it's a it's
unbelievable it's vultures man and you
think that they would be one of the most
protected and revered groups and they're
not they're just they're preyed upon
well I mean it's a lot of 18 19 20 year
olds first time out of home first time
with a paycheck first time away from
home right and they're they're
easy pickings for
stupid people that want to get them
involved in stupid stuff so um that's a
kind way this is yeah that was a really
nice way to say it this is this is a
cool thing I'm I'm proud to be
associated with this yeah me too it's
cool too glad I'm glad our financial
peace guys put that together that's a
good move
all right Bob's with us Bob is in L.A hi
Bob how are you
I'm great thank you for taking the call
sure how can we help
well I just retired I sold my business
to 51 years last week wow I'm close ask
yes yeah it's a long time how much did
you sell it for
you uh by uh 811 000. good for you man
cool thank you
I want to know well I the only debt I
have is my house it's 280 000
um if I pay it off my
net income per month will be about or
well my out goal will be a thousand
dollars less
so it's all about cash flow at this
point again with the market we are dying
don't trust putting that money in there
yeah it's not about cash flow it's about
peace of mind how old are you again
I'm 72. okay and how much other money do
you have
um
about two hundred thousand dollars in
savings about two hundred thousand
dollars in uh retirement
and I think that's it 800 and out of
taxes I'm sure you still got to pay
taxes you gotta pay taxes on the 800 yet
yes I do okay all right so we got
probably even around 775 and they live
in California so I got to pay that too
yeah okay
um yeah I'm paying off the house today
well that's what my thought was yeah
here here's the thing it may not be
advantageous on the cash flow
it will be advantageous when you lay
your head on the pillow
you'll feel like you lost weight dollars
a month in inches that's all right so
that's what that's what I fear most in
retirement well I mean here's the thing
you're going to need to invest the money
after taxes and after paying off the
thing and you're gonna have to learn
about the market and think about the
long-term implications not the
short-term implications of the market I
would agree with you that short term the
market right now sucks the economy sucks
um a lot of anger with good reason out
there uh with politicians moves and so
forth and all that stuff going on but
all of that aside
um you know unless you're ill you make
it to 80 eight years from today you're
going to be really glad you put that
money in the stock market because it
will have gone up
right well I hooked up with one of your
certified financial planners a couple of
years ago good okay so you got you got a
smart investor Pro to help you and they
can teach you and say all right yeah
that it's down right now which kind of
actually means you're at Kmart the blue
lights on there's a sale you know and so
you old people know what I'm talking
about when I said that but everybody
else is like what's a Kmart and what's a
blue light special I saw blue lights in
my rearview mirror once but anyway now
blue light was a thing they they would
turn on a blue light at the old Kmart
stores when the sale happened that was
the thing and that's what that's what
this is right now even though it's
a uh a storm out there and craziness
going on and all that stuff but uh I'm
still I haven't slowed down my 401k
contributions I haven't slowed down my
investing
um if I had some money right now that
was loose that wasn't in something and
I'm gonna leave it alone a couple years
I wouldn't think anything about putting
it in there today
because I'm I'm very confident in the
American economy overall that does not
mean I'm very confident in Washington
not try to screw it up but it just means
overall the American economy is so much
more robust than Washington is stupid it
tends to figure out a way to work its
way around that that's that's a tough
teeter-totter man that's a tough one
yeah that's a lot of weight on that one
end I'm just saying but yeah that's
right but uh uh like you know I I the
Republic
uh the United States of America the
economy the free enterprise system
capitalism are just much stronger than
political divisiveness and stupid stuff
that the FED does right now which what
they're doing is dumber than a rock but
we'll survive that we've survived much
worse things and uh and we'll Prosper
again uh the other side of that so it's
just it's easy to get caught up in the
drama of the day oh yeah particularly
today since tomorrow's the day you vote
oh there we go yeah so the drama can we
get a fever pitch if you already know
who you're going to vote for turn the
news off turn it off if you've already
decided who I'm voting for in your local
elections turn it off enjoy your day
today yeah today turn it off now I will
get I I got I got a little Ken Coleman
for tomorrow night I'm gonna pop some
popcorns and watch enjoy it enjoy it's a
movie yes yeah enjoy it and I'll I'll
probably do the same thing and uh my
favorite thing is to put up two opposing
news sites and me and Hank watch them
and be like okay here's the number just
came in and that's what they say that's
what they say that's fun yeah to
identify that neither one of them are
telling the day yeah but today uh if you
know you can have a fourth turn off man
go for a walk yeah Sun may be shining
and even if it's not it'll be better
than what you have go buy somebody's
coffee for them do something else with
your day that's a little more productive
completely agree Bob congratulations I'm
so proud for you yeah 51 years you grew
and ran a business at 72 you sell it put
a 800 000 and some change check in your
pocket I'm so proud of you he's been
running the business that's America for
a long time that's America awesome he
started that in his garage he started in
his living room on a card table like I
started this one he he know he didn't
you know nobody gave him a check he
didn't inherit anything and he's a
millionaire yeah because of it so
plugging along plugging along this this
is what I'm talking about those kinds of
people there are more of them than there
are the Nutty ones there are they're
everywhere they just don't make as much
noise as the nuts
the nuts are out there everywhere but
they're loud nuts I mean it's just you
know it's like keyboards man yeah I mean
they're good with their keyboards and
that guy he didn't even know he's not
worried about his keyboard he's making
over making money so there you go and he
made this to rack up a million dollars
in a state that he's had to give a whole
bunch of that away to well it ain't over
yet but yeah that's true
they got one last one last gouge you
know we were out there last week during
the Sacramento event and the guys coming
through the picture line talking to us
it's
Californians
it's incredible you guys oh man Texans I
mean even when Texas sucks Texans always
are like Texas is its own country
there's always Pride you know if you
move there 30 minutes ago you're proud
of Texas right
not true of California right nobody I
don't know anybody proud nobody they're
making comments about their own State
it's just like oh my gosh you guys
you need to fire some people bring your
prize that's it this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today Roy and
Corey are with us in the lobby of
financial peace are in the lobby of
Ramsey Solutions I guess I should say
used to be Financial Peace Plaza back
about 20 years ago I don't know where my
brain is anyway welcome and they're on
the debt free stage how you guys doing
great good cool how much debt have you
paid off
196 thousand and five hundred dollars
whoa very good how long did that take
about two months or no 24 months sorry
two months still impressive all right
and your range of income during that two
years
eighty thousand to a hundred and fifty
thousand cool what do y'all do for a
living I am a coder for uh one of the
health systems in Sioux Falls and I do
new product development for a
Manufacturing Company excellent well who
got the huge raise uh we uh the big
raise was we kind of did a side hustle
over covid
um really got focused and since we
really couldn't go out and do much we
decided to stay home and instead of
watching TV actually do something I like
it what'd you do what's this
um we were buying a stolen uh old
vintage tools on eBay and Facebook
Marketplace so very neat just flipping
them just flipping them that's fun way
to go guys so instead of Tiger King you
made a bunch of money yes
this is one extreme to the other
millions of Americans they blew it man
they could have been you could have been
selling old tools who knew wow so uh
what kind of debt was the 197. our house
you paid off your house looking at a
couple of weirdos very cool weirdos so
uh wow very what's the house worth uh
about 475. very good how old are you two
34 34. how much have you gotten in
retirement savings uh about 370. man
you're real close to being baby steps
millionaires Wow way to go guys way to
go or maybe you're there and I don't
know it maybe there's something else
right yeah we're close yeah well done
guys very well done so 34 years old if I
look at all the data
drinking went up TV watching went up I
think it was like a billion something
hours of the office was watched
seriously and some some of that was
consumed by me like
you guys bucked the trend who had that
first conversation how'd y'all get how'd
y'all get on this other Journey that
most of America did not get on yeah so
like our story started with like most
stories on the stage
um I was sick and tired of being sick
and tired I was battling an autoimmune
disease that literally took over like
every aspect of my life for about a year
I just when I got off of work I just sat
on the couch and I was just exhausted
and I just didn't want to do anything
one night I remember driving home from
work and my third treatment option had
failed and I was just so frustrated and
hopeless and I just remember praying on
my way home that you know if if God's
gonna take me do it now but if not show
me a way out of this I need help I need
guidance and then that night Corey uh
Corey spoke with me and she said you
know maybe we should do something you
know that's productive and so just
sitting on the couch and she knew I like
to buy and sell tools and kind of
collect them a little bit so we kind of
turn that passion into a side hustle and
then we kind of set the B Hague to get
our house paid off before we were 40. so
how'd you get connected to this whole
Ramsay way of doing things uh I took uh
Corey and I took Financial Peace in 09
when I came out of trade school and uh
we got on the program because we needed
to because uh coming right out of trade
school our hours got cut and we bought a
house right before the crash so most of
our income was going that way and then
we kind of fell off from there when we
had kids and then and jumped back on by
listening to the podcasts and on YouTube
so wow good so so my buddies who
specialize in autoimmune disorders
um will tell me that some of the at
least the symptoms are highly stress
related yes have you seen an alleviation
of your symptoms since you've become
debt free
um a little bit I'm still battling yet
looking for a maintenance medication
that's going to kind of put me under
emissions so I've been fighting for
about four and a half years now or three
and a half years now so wow wow very
good well I'm proud of you you got to be
you got to be free in this part of your
life yeah that gives you a lot of
mathematical freedom to fight the
disease it gives you the uh emotional
head space to fight it too and Corey it
gives you some peace because you've got
a husband who's hurting and you're
picking up
um a lot of the slack right and man what
a relief to have that off your plate
right for sure Wow way to go you guys
all right what do you tell people the
key paying off your freaking house when
you're 34 years old is I would say the
biggest thing is having a strong why
behind it and then alignment with your
spouse being on the same page I
definitely could have done it without
her by myself so she was definitely the
Catalyst to get it done before we were
40. so
Corey I would yeah I just
I would agree with him I'd okay you just
gotta be in the same page in the same
boat and yeah
yeah you guys but you really focused I
mean you you must have also laid down
some other stuff of course or what you
during some of this time you couldn't do
anything anyway and someone like you to
stop going out to eat there weren't any
restaurants open nope so yeah but yeah
very good way to go you guys I'm so
proud of you who are your biggest
cheerleaders people cheering you on our
three kids were our biggest cheerleaders
I love it yeah and then a lot of people
from my work definitely helped me with
the goal planning and you know following
up making sure I was on track and
everything a little accountability there
yeah okay very good good well way to go
you guys I'm talking to freaking 34 year
old millionaires man or we'll be any
minute oh my gosh you're really
impressive very very something about
being in the middle of a tornado and
saying okay we can't control this we
can't control that
let's work really hard to minimize some
of these external stressors let's take
as many stress variables off the table
as possible and y'all did it with three
little kids in the middle of a of a
pandemic in in South Dakota which means
in 40 feet of snow right you just did it
and you just kept doing it right uh
congratulations that's awesome thank you
very neat well done well done all right
we've got a copy of Total Money Makeover
for you to give away to somebody I'm
sure you've been through it the baby
steps millionaire book which you're
about to be entered into that book any
minute here good stuff and of course a
one-year membership to Financial Peace
University that whole bundle is the live
and give bundle we're going to give it
to you guys just to say thanks for
coming all the way down here hope you
enjoy Nashville while you're here all
right bring the kiddos and let's hear
their names and ages
but
come on up guys all right
all right so we got Nolan here he's now
four uh-huh now this is Gavin he is
eight and this is Bryn and she is 11.
all right way to go guys and you said
they were very involved in cheering you
all huh they they had to sacrifice a lot
with not going out for ice cream so
often we had to budget of if there's no
money in the account no ice cream yeah
we're paying off the house but now we
can go anywhere we want to yep hey kids
their excuses are gone y'all can have
ice cream whenever you want now
they gotta blame it on something else
now you'll rock your teeth
all right way to go you guys beautiful
family we're so proud of you excellent
excellent job all right Roy and Corey
bran Gavin and Nolan Sioux Falls South
Dakota 197 000 paid off in two years 24
months making 80 to 150 got the side
hustle going on the side knocked the
house out by the time they're 34 with
their retirement accounts just under a
million dollar net worth right now as
baby steps millionaires we're looking at
them right here they didn't steal any of
it and they're not famous but they're
millionaires I love it counted down
let's hear a debt-free scream three two
one
[Applause]
there is not only a
stress relief when you decide to attack
something head-on like that but there is
a sense of
dignity that you get from controlling
the controllables yeah you know you're
in a high stress tornado like you said
eight feet of snow three little kids
middle of a pandemic and you got an
autoimmune disorder oh my gosh that's
that's a serious tornado yeah it is and
so what are we gonna do watch Tiger King
or solo tools let's make let's start off
tools we're gonna do something we can do
to start a business and change the
change the equation and I love what um
Corey did here she took something that
he loved she didn't work against it
wasn't like you gotta let's take
something you love and let's see if we
can make money out of that and it was a
small side hustle turned into a bigger
side hustle now they have no house
payment love it wow you know it's just a
matter of concentrating headed right
into the middle it's not magical guys
it's hard they weren't saying it wasn't
hard it's hard all we're promising is is
that it's worth it
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Hesse is with us
in Aggieland the College Station Texas
hey esom what's up
hi Dave how are you great man how can we
help I uh I'm I'm tired to graduate next
year in the in the spring May of 2023
and I hopefully have a job lined up to
start a few months after and I'd be
making a good amount of money and I
calculated all the taxes and all the the
daily and monthly expenses that I would
have and I basically would have yearly
about 30k and I was trying to see if I
could you know what what are the best
ways to invest this money very early on
and you know should I wait on it should
I try to make more money and then invest
in something big or what should I do
okay
um the millionaires that we have studied
are slow and steady
they're not sudden
and so they develop a system like for
instance your 401k at your new workplace
and you Max it out what kind of money
you're going to be making
it's about 80 to 90k good for you good
for you okay well you're you for the
first do you have any debt
no debt good for you okay then we would
first tell you to build an emergency
fund of three to six months of expenses
and then start saving 15 of your income
uh and anything above that I would save
and invest towards a good down payment
or the cash purchase of a home later
no rush to buy a home you've got plenty
of time
but um the home later is a good thing
and uh so you know I'm gonna limit right
now at your young age you're investing
to 15 into good mutual funds uh we
spread it across four types growth
growth and income aggressive growth and
international put it in a Roth 401k with
a match and you've got the best of all
worlds or Roth IRA if you don't have a
match you want to do Roth and you want
to do a diversified portfolio a
spreading out of the investing long term
and if you'll if you'll just save 15 of
80 000 you're going to be a millionaire
by the time you're 40. if you'll just do
that but you're not going to just do
that because above that you're going to
save and uh you're going to save up and
get a house and then you get the house
paid off and then you'll be able to
invest even more because you'll be
making even more and so you're gonna
you're gonna do very well
congratulations I also encourage you to
unfollow from Instagram and Facebook and
Tick Tock and whatever new platform of
the week pops up unfollow any of of the
influencer voices that are telling you
these get rich scheme hacks on how to
buy gold or trade it's just slow and
steady man it's just slow and steady you
know yeah
um because you can you can you can start
you start to feel panicked that you're
screwing something up you're not you're
gonna miss the boat on a thing and it
just you get this fervor around you and
then you do something dumb well it yeah
it creates fomo in the investment world
and basically what you're talking about
is it's it's the junk food or the
financial World there you go yeah and if
you only put junk food in your brain
you're gonna you know your brain's gonna
be fat you know it's that simple and uh
morbidly obese yeah that's where you'll
be so yeah it's going to be a problem
and so um I was speaking to a group of
leaders
um world-class people I was actually
honored to get to be in the room uh
Friday night and um
I told them I said the the only way you
can control exactly what you said the
only way you could control your your
ability to sustain
leadership to not because leadership's
heavy yep it's hard the only way you can
control it is control your inputs you've
got to control your inputs and so if
you're constantly eating intellectual
junk food and you don't eat any you know
protein vegetables whatever if the
intellectual World which means read a
good non-fiction book unplug Facebook
they're not real friends they're not
going to help you change a tire
um and uh you know the the people if you
follow people that do comments after
some of these things you understand why
some species kill their young I mean
it's just you know it's just it's the
dumbest of the dumb it's the the bottom
of the proverbial burial of humanity
showing up there and that's not where
you want to get advice about anything in
your life right
um it is the glorified version of a cat
chasing the lasers what it's down to so
you've got to be really careful to
control your inputs and um you know uh
the social guys came to me the other day
our social media team and said you know
there's some complaints in the social
world that Dave you don't follow anybody
on your Instagram which is not my
Instagram anyway they run it right I put
one I put something on there about twice
a month everything else is put on there
by them and they do a good job and I'm
proud of it it's not that thing but
um
yeah I said well there's a reason I
don't follow
more than about 20 people on Instagram I
hadn't found anybody
you know I follow our stuff so if I open
up the account I can see what John
deloney's doing I can see what Rachel
Cruz is doing you know that kind of
stuff because Rachel and George they
actually do this crap you know
um but the um you know but the rest of
it's yeah you're right I think that's
really good input to guard your inputs
Dan is with us Dan is in Des Moines hi
Dan welcome to the Ramsay show
hey guys thanks uh so much for having me
I'm uh a bit nervous but pretty excited
no no troubles we never lost a patient
how can we help
yeah so I am 29 and my wife is just
turned 28 um I was a former law
enforcement officer uh was forced to
retire about two years ago due to
incidents from the job
um because of that no no physical
limitations uh to speak of but
because of that um they gave me I
received about 2 500 a month
um my wife and I just sold our first
house and we moved into our new house in
April so that covers the mortgage
essentially but we were also blessed
with uh twins about five months ago yay
which death
they are beautiful and healthy uh and
it's been a huge blessing but obviously
you know change things
um so I I sold my dream truck last month
it was last month was when I really
first started following you guys
um and that already made me feel better
so our only debt currently is student
loans so I have 45 000 in private 20 000
in federal my wife has 28 000.
um in our savings account we have 45
000 in cash we also have 20 000 in
mutual funds that aren't protected by a
retirement account
um and then we have about 50 000 in Roth
uh
um between the two of us so my question
is what's your household income
so with my new career I make about 90k
and my wife is a kindergarten teacher we
just paid for her Masters 90 include the
30k you're getting from the police
department
nope that's separate okay so you're on
top of 90 you got another 30. so that's
120 or you know one I'm sorry yeah 120
and then your wife makes how much
she makes about 70k excellent okay so
you got 190 000 income
you were we are we are certainly very
blessed yeah that's awesome
question comes in if I paid 44k right
leaving that thousand dollar emergency
fund pulled 20K from the mutual funds
um
exactly but my problem is we pay about 2
000 a month in BayCare so 500 you make
190.
Dan you're not a policeman anymore
you're good
you are still looking for the worst case
scenario the guy coming around the
corner is not coming yeah you're doing
well
and if he does come in you're gonna have
no debts
awesome and that's what I knew you
that's what I figured you guys would say
but you know getting this first large
sum of money you know for the first time
in your life it's like you wanna you
wanna hold on to it but you said you
can't beat Dave ish and that's why I
plan on coming up to Eden Prairie uh
next week to try to talk to you guys in
person as well fun well I hope you can
make it yeah we it is sold out but you
hang on and we'll have them get you a
couple of tickets if you want to come uh
the uh here's the thing okay it's not
Dave ish that matters because Dave
really doesn't matter at the end of the
story what matters here is is we have
you have to decide is the system that we
use at Ramsey really
really the shortest
fastest
way to wealth
is it really yep and if you really
believe it is then you follow the system
if you really believe your system is
then you'll go with your system
but if I woke up in your shoes you know
what I would do brother I'd write a
check today and be rid of two of these
student loans I'd be sitting there with
the 28 000 and make 190 I tighten that
old budget up feed those little twin
babies and I dump the rest of it let's
clear that loan up man you can do it
into it so hey thank you man we
appreciate you calling you hang on uh
Austin will pick up we'll give you a
couple tickets for Eden Prairie we'll be
there next or that's not the next week
that's this week it's a couple days this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey it's John deloney co-host of the
Ramsey show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the Ramsey show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show that is Don Cash's king and
the paid off Home Mortgage has taken the
place of the BMW as the status symbol of
choice we help people build wealth do
work they love and create actual amazing
relationships Dr John deloney Ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author host of the Dr John deloney show
mental health expert is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Hardy is going to start this hour in
Atlanta Georgia hi Hardy how are you
hey Dave how you doing I'm great and
great good man how can we help
yeah um okay so I I completed the the
baby steps
um officially I would say February but I
paid off my mortgage in December
this is Pat December way to go man
thanks and and now
um all right about my job due to covet
went out of business and that was April
but they paid everyone up to on five
months
and so technically now I don't have a
job but I've completed the baby steps I
have my my um my paid off mortgage I
have my my um
security way to go
why don't you have it why don't you have
a job why don't you have a job
okay well when they when they let us off
um
to go find a job why haven't you found
one
because it is a little complicated as
far as with the um well I was in school
last year and I was trying to get out of
the field that I was in
I I was a machine operator and I was in
school at the same time for HVAC
technician
so um this year with me just finishing
up
um some more of the classes due to covet
I had to continue going to the classes
because we wasn't allowed to go to the
college while Cobra was going on so it
it it it it it it it prevented us from
being able to so you're trying to get a
two-year certification in HVAC
yes yes I don't know not the certificate
I got a diploma I was yeah did you
finish it
yes I just did I just recently that's
what oh when do you start your new job
well I have been I haven't I haven't um
well I've been working with people
um who have their own businesses and I
and I do that but I mainly do handyman
work since when they laid me off I mean
you knew you were getting ready to
finish your HVAC degree why didn't you
go talk to HVAC companies and get a job
as an HVAC guys what you're trained for
why haven't you done that
because I was nervous because because
the Kobe stopped us from learning enough
and and and and and with some of the
guys in my class tried to go get certain
jobs the people was like we didn't know
enough you didn't even kind of heavy
hearty Hardy you haven't even tried man
somebody told you
yeah somebody told you along the way
that you weren't good enough and that's
bullcrap you are good enough you are
good enough
people are begging for help right now
begging they got like I got I passed a
big billboard that said we pay 401K
we'll we'll take your mother to lunch I
mean he'll do anything to get you her
house come be an HVAC you are sitting on
a Golden Ticket man and you're doing
handyman work because you're scared go
get a job you got it listen okay listen
my kids need you because when something
like that breaks in my house their
father is useless because I have that
certification Mike yeah I could care
less about here too you've learned all
you're gonna learn in the classroom now
you got to get out there and figure out
how to do it in the wild yeah and you're
gonna have to learn you're gonna screw
stuff up and your boss is going to be
like what did you do and you have to go
make it right that's just part of
learning especially in a trade man party
you you brought up this job layoff
and the fear around covid
and the Damage that kovid did to your
life and your future in your mind has
punched you in the stomach and you still
ain't got your breath back okay shut you
down that's right so we're telling you
throw back your shoulders get back in
the game go hit somebody that's right
you have and I love that I know you got
the breath knocked out of you and I know
you were scared I know covet got you I
know you lost your job and I get all
that and that that takes some of your
confidence away take some of your
Swagger away but we're telling you
you're in a business you pick the right
thing you can go land something by the
end of the day tomorrow man and not just
to something you could go make some
money yes yeah but it's all about
Swagger again and it's all about and you
go you know what I heard that maybe some
of the stuff we learned in class wasn't
right if you guys will teach me that
stuff you're gonna find me to be a hard
worker they'll go okay
and hey here's another thing I worked
for two decades in one career and I got
pretty good at it and then I switched
careers I took a complete left turn I
don't think a day goes by but I don't
ask you Dave hey how do I hit this and
you make sure I hit the clock here James
is coaching me on how to you're starting
at the bottom so ask a whole bunch of
questions you're brand new at a new
trade yeah but be prep be there and be
going I I don't know how to do it but
you're gonna catch me caring you're
going to catch me showing up you're
gonna catch me working hard
um but you don't have to you don't have
to come in there with a PhD in HVAC
you're just going in there get a Wharton
job fixing air conditioner man go do it
Go Get It Go Get It Go Get It yeah and a
lot of those guys that you're working
for don't have a certification or and
certainly don't have a quote certificate
or degree it's either one and and I was
gonna keep piling around Hardy that
sense of you've got defeated I guarantee
you that's playing into your romantic
relationships that's playing into your
if you're a parent that's playing into
all of you man stand up you're hearty
you got knocked down it's time to get
back up yep let's do this man hey we're
always giving away uh the most fun you
can have with money especially at
Christmas and now we've launched the
Ramsey Christmas Cash giveaway go to
ramsaysolutions.com giveaway you can
enter for your chance to win 500 prizes
or the five thousand dollar Grand Prize
winner every day no purchase is
necessary go to ramseysolutions.com
giveaway and right now in time for
Christmas the ten dollar sale is back
that means you can buy almost any of our
books including Baby Steps millionaires
including King Coleman's book paycheck
to purpose and including a whole bunch
of the conversation cards questions for
humans I've got the I've got the
Christmas deck here man the Christmas
deck so awkward Christmas family hey
this is us saving your families during
the holidays Thanksgiving Christmas that
we're not allowed to talk about covet
and you're not allowed to talk about
politics you have to pull out this day
that's right so Dave which Christmas
song Would you never pay would I mean
which Christmas song would you pay 67 to
never hear again
I I
don't know I like them all
I would rather set myself on fire than
listen to pahrumpa pum pum ever again
that could be on the list I'll go with
that if someone said hey I'd like to hit
you with a stick or I'm gonna play
Little Drummer Boy on repeat I would
gladly eat you stick gladly all right
what Christmas movie gets way too much
hype oh oh oh
foreign
man just say it you just thought of it
Christmas story or the uh the one with
the BB gun
shoot your eye oh yeah yeah that one's
way too much hype on that what's it
called it's not the Christmas story is
it yeah it's a Christmas story it is the
Christmas story I Think Jesus is the
Christmas story so I'm so confused oh
here we go there's a Jesus guy well I
know I am oversaved so there you go
that's just that's it so you got to
bring Jesus come on here we go well Dave
who are you
this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
thank you for joining us our question of
the day comes from blinds.com
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings you get free samples
free shipping new promos all the time if
you want a deal always use the promo
code Ramsey to get the best possible
deal
all right today's question comes from
Joseph in New Mexico Joseph writes I'm
27 years old engaged to be married and
we have a young son I own an I.T
Consulting business that last year made
130 Grand in profit after paying all
expenses including my salary I'm
grateful for all the opportunities that
help my career in financial growth but I
feel stuck I've been putting more
thought into what I want to do with my
life and I realize I'm sacrificing a lot
of time with my family I want to slow
down regroup and regain focus on my life
but that feels impossible with all my
work responsibilities the other day I
saw how happy my son was when I was able
to clear my schedule and pick him up
from school it truly made me question a
lot of my past decisions I want to
change but I'm afraid that means I
wasted a lot of time growing something
just to shut it down is there such thing
as a work life balance
what do you think Dave
I don't think I'm qualified to answer
this well
[Laughter]
I'll go backwards no there's no such
thing as a work-life balance it's not
real it's a myth it doesn't exist there
are seasons right and there's seasons of
Madness and wildness right now we are on
the road I'm writing another book I am
all over the place and so back in
September or maybe it was August my wife
and I sat down and mapped out the next
four months and we knew it was going to
be bananas and we have built in touch
points all through that time because we
knew and when the kids asked for stuff
yeah it stinks and um it's also part of
it and because of this season it's going
to allow for a different season on the
other side of this thing so
um no there's not this thing as
work-life balance there's being honest
about what season we're in sometimes you
wear a coat because it's winter and
other times you're short because it's
the summer same thing when it comes to
your life
um I can tell you right now Joseph your
kid was really happy to see you if you
picked them up every single day in about
a week and a half he'd be really tired
of seeing you that's just the way that
works man uh those moments are special
or great dog's happy to see every night
because I don't even know you've been
gone
um the um
yeah so I don't what we don't have in
this email or this uh where Harvard came
in
um is what the number of hours you're
putting in and what your long-term goal
is and those kinds of things okay
in general
the idea that I don't want to work much
so I can play with my kid is not going
to work well with you long term
okay in general
no one in the equation is going to
respect or like you at the end of that
story
they're just not yep okay so uh in
general now I mean I'm talking like I
want to work 10 hours a week and I want
to uh you know be the uh interfere with
the teacher at the elementary school
because I'm there so much you know that
can I I just you know whatever uh so uh
but what I think I'm hearing is that you
don't see any end of this in sight and I
don't know how many hours you're working
if you're working 40 to 60 hours and
you're running a business and you're
paying yourself a salary plus 130 well
Welcome to the Real World right oh well
that's exactly right and the good news
is you're self-employed and if your kid
is doing a
uh Christmas play you can go you can
just decide I'm gonna book around that
and you can go you can decide that but
uh do you pick them up every day from
school probably not oh well you're
running a business you work you're
earning my money for your family it's
not bad you're not a workaholic and you
don't have issues there's nothing like
like that going on
um and you're not burning out you're
doing fine you got a good career so the
only parallel I know is this when I was
30
two years old we started this show
I was working 16-hour days
ridiculous hours
during those times during that time for
about two years
my kids were little
my wife if you sat her down today would
still say something snarky about that
period of time about her being a single
mom
but during that time even though she's
snarky about it and harbors some
bitterness her life turned out okay I
can tell you that because we for a
period of time turned the heat up and
got the got the stove going
you know we got we got the thing cooking
and so then later on uh the next year if
there was a prom
uh we did not book live events around
the prom date if there was a uh I
coached my son's ice hockey uh so that
means on Saturdays and every night
whatever I was down there coaching him
when he's seven eight nine years old
that kind of stuff for years I coached
his ice hockey team and um
so we were there I mean we would go to
the lake and I taught them all to do
stuff behind the boat drag them around
on the tube throw them off and do mean
Dad stuff to them and all that stuff I
mean so we we have all of those memories
too but we also have a thing I did not
take 12 weeks off as the father
that was working when my children were
born
I took 12 hours off
and it never occurred to me had I taken
more than 12 hours off my wife who grew
up in the country where hard work is
taught uh would have said what the bleep
are you doing here get out you need to
get out of here you got to pay for this
kid you need to get your butt back to
work so what I hear in this is but but
my point is I've had balance come and go
here or there and then there's times
it's winter and you have to you have to
turn the heat up you got to go and right
now you know you got the thing running
it sounds like I don't know why you need
to be burning a hundred and eighty
degrees it boil over just turn the heat
down a little bit and work 40 60 hours
50 hours whatever and then another week
you know work 30. I don't think this is
about his kid I see this over and over
um where somebody's 27 to 35 they've
gone all in on a particular career and
then they found out they had to work
they don't like it or they have to work
really hard right or I thought this
would just be super fun all the time
whatever the thing is and then you start
looking around in your life for reasons
to do something different so what I
would tell you Joseph is if you want to
do something different own it and do
something different don't blame this on
your kid if you want to do something
different and
um you don't like doing it jobs but you
want to go be a police officer a
counselor go be a police officer
counselor you don't need to justify it
in a different way just just do it
um in a safe but here's the appropriate
way expect
if you're going to avoid mediocrity
in your life in any area of your life
it's going to work hard expect to pay a
price absolutely if you want to get your
body in shape to run a marathon expect
to pay a price if you want your marriage
to be good expect to concentrate and be
an unusually intentional about that more
so than your idiot friends on Instagram
that's right you know expect to work
hard at a career over a long period of
time before you make any freaking big
money that's right and before you get to
ah and this Instagram world we live in
where if you just do this then you can
have your private jet next year it's
just not real man it's not real well and
here you know if you want to work four
days a week
or you want to work from home which
means work part-time
and you want to do that expect the
different result
expected diminished return so because
here's the thing mediocre if that's your
target you're going to hit it
I had this um Epiphany Dave I did
something I shouldn't have done way back
in the day and I got online and looked
what the the top salaries were at the
University I was working was and I found
out my boss made two or three times what
I was making and I was working 24 7 365
and like a young idiot I got so
indignant
and it wasn't two or three or four weeks
later my boss calls me and says hey
um I want you to start coming to these
meetings with me because I'm going to
teach you how CFO talks and how a
president talks and how board talks and
it was a gift and it was about two or
three weeks in and follow him around to
these meetings that I realized oh crap
he earns that money yeah he's like
smarter than me and stuff but he's
carrying the whole thing yeah on his
shoulder every decision that I make
reflects on him and he has to call make
the call on this and on this and I
realized oh there's no Free Ride man
yeah those guys who put in the time and
they get this they make this money it
comes at a cost it's not the it's not
the five minute repair it's the 25 years
to learn how to do that repair five
minutes that's right repair that's the
thing so there's a price to be paid sir
somewhere in your life yep that'll give
you your work-life balance that'll get
you there that's what our gazelle
intensity that we teach us for a short
period of time you just go crazy and get
out of debt so that you can live without
the stress of that the price to be paid
or you can be YOLO and be paying
payments the rest of your goddamn stupid
life this was the Ramsay show
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America we're so glad
you're with us in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage
Christina is with us hi Christina how
are you good how are y'all better than
we deserve where do you live I'm from
Stephenville Texas which is about an
hour Southwest of Fort Worth oh yeah
perfect well welcome to Nashville
how much you paid off I paid off 39
414.23 in 19 months way to go and your
range of income during that time it
started about 40 000 and then between
like the million side hustles I had
probably up to about 65 000. okay out of
the million side hustles which was the
best one the one that paid the best
um definitely the pumpkin patch so I'm a
manager at a pumpkin patch every fall
and my bosses Josh and Ashley they're
amazing and they've really blessed me so
really been very generous financially so
out of feeling you're a pretty good
pumpkin patch man how do you how do you
what is a pumpkin patch manager do do
they come alive at night like what are
you doing well one time my boss told me
that my life as a pumpkin patch manager
is like a Hallmark film so I'll just let
you take that one for how it is it's
really not like that it's kind of crazy
it's a lot of moving Parts all right
there's a lot going on here there's a
lot going on in the pumpkin patch I'm
telling you all right so what kind of
debt was the 39 000. Oh my gosh I had
everything so I had um 5500 in a credit
card 8 000 on a trailer AKA like a
camper like trailer trash
um and student loans of 26 000. okay
yeah are you living in this trailer so I
was while I was paying off my debt and
um on a camping trailer yes sir
yeah and Stephenville yeah there it is
on the screen no way that's not a bad
looking trailer no it was really nice
camping trailers yeah yeah they're
really how much did you owe on it I
started well I had already paid off
about half of it so whenever I started
my journey it was about eight thousand
dollars okay so it's paid off now yes
sir and I've sold it and you don't live
there anymore I don't live in a shoebox
no sorry that's good good I'm proud of
you wow okay how old are you
uh like 23 plus or minus five years
this math thing is tough hey man okay I
was 27 whenever I finished so we'll go
with that number you're not old it's
okay you don't have to lie about your
age okay you realize how old Dave is you
are with me
you are all right you're like right
behind him watch out that's right I'm
right behind him I'll just play Little
Drummer Boy again and keep that up but
the uh okay so uh wow okay so you're 27
25 years old and you say all right this
is not working uh whatever I've learned
to this point about money is a disaster
I I don't like my life something's got
to change what happened that flipped the
switch for you and how did you get
connected to this Ramsey stuff yeah yeah
so it's actually funny I was in I one of
my college classes got dropped so I had
to pick up another class and it was
personal finance and ironically the
professor that taught it was actually
really bad with money and so one day he
was like have you ever heard of Dave
Ramsey and I'm like no and then I
started listening to your podcast I was
like well look him up and I started
listening to your podcast and after that
I was like oh my gosh this guy is like
very common sense I had been doing the
envelope system I just didn't know it
was your thing
I stole it from my great grandmother
okay perfect yeah and so I just started
listening to the podcast and right about
then is when covid hit and that was a
really scary time because I had two jobs
and I was finishing up college and I
lost both jobs basically overnight and
so I was like oh my gosh I am never
gonna be in this situation again like I
owe so much money I was playing the game
Dave like I was playing the game so I
had student loans that were paying my
credit card payment and I was using my
credit card to pay my tuition and then I
was also using student loans to do fix
my Jeep like it was just a mess and I
would just swipe my card my debit and my
credit card and I just like wouldn't
even look at the balances and finally it
got to that point your show really
convicted me I was like I can't do this
anymore like never again this is my
never again moment and so
um I just kind of started working the
plan and you know it took me a year and
a half so one thing I'll say is like the
Lord did provide like this whole time it
was just insane because the math does
not work you know it doesn't work to pay
off as much as your income almost in a
year and a half and so he just kept
providing me with opportunities for side
hustles I actually worked like six
different side hustles during this time
so I was working a lot was it worth it
it was so worth it I think about it now
and I'm like yeah I don't ever just for
a season yeah yeah definitely it was the
longest shortest time of my life where
did you get this thing inside of you
that when
um that caused you you had this
instantaneous reaction I mean you're in
denial money's flying everywhere it's
not going anywhere
um and as soon as you go wait a minute
this is stupid I gotta stop you just
stopped I mean you didn't it sounded
like there was no negotiation in your
head like trying to talk you into
continuing the other way you just said
this didn't work and I stopped well I
will say that with covid and stuff
everybody was going literally insane and
y'all were like it's okay like we're
gonna get through this and ball blah so
honestly like partially I just was
listening to y'all to stay calm and then
I was like wow like yeah I should do the
money thing too I guess what makes it
different is that because I started
listening on about four months later
when I started my debt free Journey
whatever I got like my first big girl
job yeah and so and my income was more
stable and stuff and so I guess what
changed it is I was 23 when I came back
to college and so I was already an adult
like I had been living an adult life and
then I got into college and just went
willy-nilly with finances
um you know my my Mimi and my dad were
helping me with money and everything and
I just squandered it like I was taking
out student loans paying cash for a
little bit of my tuition but just not
managing it wisely and so once I started
hearing y'all's material I was like oh
my gosh I'm 25 I can't waste any more
time so what's your day job
um I'm a loan administrator at a Farm
Credit bank yeah we do loans for farmers
and ranchers yeah and what's your what's
your take on pay that job
um well it's about 40 ish okay and so
yeah between the other side jobs is
where I got the rest of the income okay
I was just doing the quick envelope math
in my head
um if you worked six jobs and made 65
000 here's what I'm telling you you're
brilliant and you're not scared of hard
work and you are able to look at a
problem and say I can work through that
and head directly into it and those
people are making a whole bunch of money
these days okay and so I just want you
to not settle wherever you happen to be
thank you thankfully I love my job
I think you're probably worth twice what
you're making at least yeah thanks yes
yeah at least even the ability to see
something and face it and step into it
instead of run and hide your head in the
corner yeah and then it's it's a big
deal and you've got you got the stuff
that's why I was asking about it I was
sensing the exact same thing and there's
this old saying the the harder I worked
the luckier I got right that's like man
I just took kept taking on jobs and I
don't know what happened but I just kept
making more money the Lord blessed me
when I once more yeah he did yeah he
does that and it was job four and five
and six right yeah well I will say that
at my job they're extremely generous
with bonuses so you know I make 40 000
base salary but
um with the bonus and everything it's
it's
a man they were just saying you're good
you're good you're excellent excellent
hey we got a copy of Total Money
Makeover for you to give away to
somebody because I'm sure you've been
talking about this and people are going
okay I'm ready to do it uh baby steps
millionaires I think you're going to be
one pretty quick here
um by the time by the time you have the
10th anniversary of your 23rd birth
there you go
all right and Financial Peace University
one year membership we'll get you
through that where you can get all the
details and let's finish this uh this
portion of the Life Training up you're
incredible you're a very neat young lady
thank you all for having me a lot of fun
a lot of fun to talk to people like you
and um there's just uh moms and dads
when you raise one that will just turn
and face a storm like that it is um it's
uh it's rewarding it's it's gratifying
what's one piece of wisdom you'd give to
somebody in your shoes right now I had a
sticky note on my Dash in my car and it
said life is too short to spend it in
debt and that is something that I just
really told myself like every moment and
it was really convenient because like
any time I'd want to go buy something
that would be staring back at me so yeah
life is too short to spend it in debt
heading to the heading to the store oh I
gotta go back I'm pretty sure way to go
all right Christina from Fort Worth
Texas area Stevensville to be precise 39
1000 paid off in 19 months making 40 to
65 with a bazillion side jobs counted
down let's hear a debt free scream three
two
impressive wow love it love it love it
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Marie is with us
in Sacramento we were just there hi
Marie how are you
I'm good how are you guys better than we
deserve what's up
um my husband and I are having a
discussion about paying off our mortgage
this is our situation he is active duty
military we know that we'll be stationed
here
um for about three and a half more years
but then we'll be moving to the Midwest
so we're trying to figure out if we
should pay down the rest of our mortgage
like as aggressively as possible or
should we invest that money for a future
down payment at our next TV station
you're going to sell the house when you
move
so either way you're going to get the
money back
it's not like we're spending it
right
no I mean you're either going to put it
in an investment or you're going to pay
down the house either way the money is
going to be sitting there when you move
and going to come out of the investment
or come out of the house and be used for
the Midwest house correct
yes okay so I think if you get that out
on the table and say that out loud
sometimes that changes the way it sits
in your brain
because sometimes people feel like when
they're paying off their house that like
they're spending money or something it's
not going away you get it back when you
sell the house
so you're making the interest rate as
your rate of return because when you
don't pay interest on it you save that
interest right by paying it off or
paying it down either one or you make
the rate of return on an investment the
difference though is is you can cash out
an investment by a bass boat you really
can't do that with your house
it's what we call a forced Savings Plan
once you pay down the house you are
stuck only two ways to get that money
out refinance which you wouldn't do or
sell the house which you don't do until
you move so it keeps you from spending
the money and you get a rate of return
and you're moving towards wealth I'm
paying down the house
um you know I thought I would call and
get your opinion just so I could have
that to talk to my husband no and and
here's the weird thing too after doing
this for 30 years
sometimes people's plans don't work out
can you imagine that is true
yeah and I don't know what series of
events would occur for you to remain
there
I don't know what those would be or to
be delayed there for five extra years or
to move sooner because something else
happened I don't know what any of those
things are but seldom have my plans that
I laid out worked out exactly like I
thought they were going to my never do
day and never well that's what my that's
kind of my point none of them so yeah
I'm paying it down because that works no
matter what happens so there's this fear
permeating the uh the interwebs that if
you pay it on your house now it's going
to be worth less than three to five
years
the house values are not affected by the
debt on the house
say that again the house goes up in
value based on what someone will pay for
it not based on what you owe on it right
but the fear being if I pay off my my
mortgage in at 600 000 and suddenly I
have to sell it for 400 I've lost 200
000 you you've lost it anyway because if
you so if you haven't paid it down and
you sell it at a loss you've got to pay
the difference
you should start a radio show Dave
but that's not what they say on the
internets man I know but if you at least
I know I know exactly if you owe 500 000
on the house and it goes from 600 down
to 400 you owe a hundred more on your
house than it's worth they don't give
you a break on it and so the illusion of
having a hundred grand in the checking
account is the Hedge against that isn't
real it's not real they're gonna take
that money you know this is why they
should teach you know basic accounting
in the 11th grade but they don't that's
called a balance sheet entry so oh god
um the internet that's just hey that's
what he was asking the Internet is just
oh that's just no no no no he's just
saying he wants the money easier to
access so when they move they can just
do the move and then he's going to try
to buy the house in the midwest before
he sells the house in Sacramento and I'm
going to prevent him from doing that
because he's not going to have any money
gotcha because he's going to tie it up
in the house he's got to sell the
Sacramento house his house and not going
to say we're going to keep that one as a
rental while we moved to Kansas City no
we're not either we're selling that
dadgum thing
and it does not change the value of a
home whether you pay it down or not
that's a different issue but yeah both
of those got covered in one call look
how good we are open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Ronnie's in Houston hey Ronnie what's up
hello Dave and Dr John how are you
better than we deserve sir how can we
help uh same here uh
nine years old I'm retired from a big
city Fire Department my wife has retired
from a school district and uh
we have about a hundred thousand in a
money market account that basically pays
nothing and uh I have a we have no debt
and I have a uh an account it's called a
deferred retirement option plan
and there it's a uh a fixed rate every
year
and there is 1.4 million in it I've
never taken any money out of it since I
started this account and I know I've got
rmds coming up in a few years when I
turned 72. you have rmds on this account
yes sir this is this account is uh it's
a it's affiliated with my retirement
fund is it a foreign
to be honest with you Dave I don't know
the number I don't that's a lot of money
congratulations I'm glad you got a
million four I have no idea what this
account is you've stumped it well yeah
it's it's tax deferred account right
it's affiliated with my pension system
and it it's basically when you have 20
years of service you can sign up for
this and the valuation is a million four
yes sir okay but there's no lump sum
option available to roll it to an IRA
okay does it die when you die surely not
no no it's it goes to my beneficiary not
like a pencil
it's yeah yes my pension doesn't come
out of this money but it's an account
that started way back and uh I mean I
could go down there and other than have
to pay taxes on it I could draw it all
out if I wanted to
but uh okay here's what I want you to do
because I'm ignorant and I don't know
the answer
if I so if I woke up in your shoes I'd
have to go get the answer and you called
the wrong guy because I can't help you I
don't know what you've got uh go to one
of our smartvester pros and sit down
with them and have them unpack this and
teach you what this is
um I think I'm hearing it's a fixed rate
of return probably a lower rate of
return and I think I might be hearing
that you would probably be better off to
roll that to some mutual funds in an IRA
you're still going to have rmds with it
if you have rmds with it now required
minimum distributions of 70 and a half
72 and a half I do know what that is
um but so it sounds like it's in that
class of products but um I want to make
first I want to make sure that all the
money is going to stay in your family
that you don't lose it like you do a
pension when you die the second thing I
want to make sure of is that you don't
have a lower rate of return and that you
if you moved it you couldn't get instead
of getting six you could get 11 or 12 in
good mutual funds over the next 25 years
that's a lot of difference on a million
four and they'll help you get some of
that 100 000 working that's too much of
an emergency fund that's too much
sitting there
um uh man that's a mess so um yeah but
yeah you just need to get better advice
than the guy you called well and man
it's yet again somebody who's been just
chipping away at this thing and putting
money in the account I've never touched
it and I just went and looked and it's
got 1.4 million in it yeah that was not
an inheritance no for you people that
practice snowflakeery and it wasn't a uh
it wasn't a savings account that you
could that he drew out of he's not a
crook he didn't steal from anyone he's
not a famous Hollywood actor he's a guy
that worked and worked and worked and
worked and saved and saved and saved and
saved and now he's a millionaire and
it's not your money and you're not
entitled to his money keep your
socialist hands off of it this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show where that is dumb
cash is king and the paid off Home
Mortgage has taken the place of the BMW
as the status symbol of choice we help
people build wealth new work they love
and create actual amazing relationships
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author and host
of the Dr John deloney show is my
co-host today Tina is in Pensacola to
start off this hour hi Tina how are you
I'm better than I deserve how are you
guys just the same how can we help today
John
[Music]
known in 2020
um
we
about this time of the year back in 2020
um I called in I was my husband and I
were in debt and I had just been
diagnosed with stage four breast cancer
oh man
um
I we have savings to pay off the debt
but I was my husband and I were both
scared to do so
I'm about thirty thousand dollars in
that back then and
um John and your co-host at the time you
walked me through it and you gave me
um gifted names
a coach for four months which was
amazing
and um and call and give you an update I
love it well thank you so much for
circling back one of the biggest
challenges of this job is we talked to
people for just a few minutes and then
we we they they head off into the ether
and so I'm really gracious that you
Circle back how you doing thank you
um my cancer is stable so I went from
um my gosh we got to do all this and I
can't die and make my husband dead and
um you know along with the grief process
that was a big worry for me was that I
was going to lead him
with all this debt to worry about as
well as me you know
me
um of course during that worry I totally
forgot that we have life insurance so it
wouldn't have been that you know the
money part wouldn't have been as big if
you lose what I thought it was but you
know but you know you don't you don't
think about that when you're in the
thick of the fire that's right so that
um 26 and a half months later uh my
diagnosis that I'm stable my cancer is
under control and it hasn't grown it
hasn't it hasn't spread any programs and
it already has and we're we had some you
know cash flowing cash flowing my
medical stuff
um you know because insurance we have
but co-pays and deductibles are
expensive yep
um
we've
we're back in about ten thousand dollars
into the debt because of it but I have a
plan we're still on budget and I've got
about six months and we'll be out of
debt again wow along with still
continuing to cash flow
um the debt came December of last year
um hit us
um with actually not mine my husband
needed some major dental work and
um so he hadn't planned on that so let's
let's put the uh let's put the debt down
for a second
how are you
I am
do you know sure every every day I am
grateful and gratitude to be here I have
sticky notes all over my all over the
house to remind myself that every day
that I wake up and my feet hit the floor
and I'm not in pain is a great amazing
day there you go how's your husband
doing
he is as long as I'm doing good he's
doing good
it's a lot of hey that's a lot of
pressure on you right because you get to
have bad days and he gets to have good
days too
no when I have bad days he he tries
being strong for me but I
um I've always been the one in the
family to wear the weight of the on the
shoulders
so this has been an adjustment for both
of us for me
um allowing him to help me when I've
always been the one helping him and kids
and everybody else
that role change has been
a learning curve definitely but my
husband has been amazing and has stepped
up to the plate more than I ever thought
he not wood but could or emotionally
Tina I am
um
you've made my heart feel big today and
I'm grateful for you I'll go home with a
smile on my face I'm glad you're still
with us and I'm glad to hear about your
hard work whether it's paying off debt
or whether it is having to learn a new
way to grieve or whether it is having to
learn a new way it is to do life because
you are the fixer and all of a sudden
you needed somebody to sit down with you
and say how can I help and you allowed
them into your life
um it it will go down as one of my
life's great honors to having been able
to talk to you and get to know you and
I'm really really proud of you thank you
so much for for blessing us and for all
these people listening
you're welcome thank you for being there
10 years ago when I needed help getting
to know where to turn you got it that's
why we come down here darling yeah thank
you very much I'm glad you're doing well
that's a good word it's a good word open
phones here at triple eight eight two
five five two two five you're right what
you said earlier in that call we don't
usually hear the end of the story yeah
good or bad no we do hear good if they
come and do the debt free stream you
know you you I called in Dave and you
yelled at me about my car payment and
now here I'm two years later after I got
pissed off at you and I sold the car and
yeah we do get to hear the end of those
stories sometimes but um but yeah those
kinds of things there
um uh you don't know how they're gonna
turn out yeah you know
um
we had a young man uh working of course
that was on our payroll for the last two
years but has been fighting cancer and
we just lost him yep
um he graduated to Heaven about about
six or eight weeks ago I guess and then
we've got another team member that's
been out two years fighting breast
cancer and she's back to work one day a
week yep coming back a little bit at a
time her and her funny little haircut
it's amazing it's amazing I'm so happy
for her funny little haircut
oh yeah she was in back in last week and
we love her dearly Melissa and uh but
she's been on the payroll again for two
years and while she's been fighting this
stuff and one you know graduates to
heaven and one gets to work in the
coffee shop so so how it works
um the other day uh I was doing that
show with uh Dr Jordan Peterson on his
show and we talked about how sometimes
when you're working through anxiety you
tend to roll off and think of the worst
case scenarios the worst thing that
things are going to happen and they tend
to have a compound interest effect they
take they you think about them you start
dwelling on them you start rehearsing
them and they have a magical way of
coming true
and self-fulfilling prophecy you can do
the other side too and that's the part
that we don't ever think of is what if
we started thinking about what happens
in two years if I'm still here what
happens if my marriage is a little bit
better we've done hard work it may not
work out that way but let's go ahead and
live that way and it doesn't always work
out like some magical you know pixie
dust but
when you do open your eyes two years as
she said every day with my eyes put my
feet on the floor and I got another day
and I got another day and I got another
day you look back over the last two
years and you are amazed at how far
you've come and it tends to have it just
tends to have a compound interest effect
on the positive way too the mind is very
powerful Dr Caroline Leith talks about
that the a negative thought literally
has a physical shape in the brain that's
now found it yes it looks like a pretty
ugly little mushroom cloud that actually
she showed us pictures of it it's pretty
incredible yeah good positive thoughts
are there for you well done Tina well
done this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
well if you haven't heard it's the
economy stupid oh my gosh what a mess
stagflation inflation
digestion it's all out there
indigestion indigenous America we want
you to keep digesting yeah that's good
no we have a problem though I'm telling
you the economy's got you looking over
your shoulders we hear it from everybody
and we understand and that's why we're
on the road doing the Building Wealth
live events we're out here spreading
hope telling you you are in charge and
you can do it we want people to know
that regardless of what's going on in
Washington DC with the Island of Misfit
Toys that you are in a position to take
care of your own life and we will show
you how in fact our Building Wealth live
events have been such a hit that last
week we added more cities to the spring
lineup we're heading to Minneapolis uh
this week and it is a sold out event
thank you very much we're heading to San
Antonio next week and it is a sold out
event thank you very much which is a me
Rachel Cruz George Campbell Dr John
deloney Ken Coleman and we're adding
Nashville January the 12th and Salt Lake
City April the 24th tickets are on sale
right now tickets start at 39 dollars
don't wait to get your passes prices
will be going up as we approach sellouts
we raise the prices the other spring
wealth spring Building Wealth live tours
are sold out of the VIP levels but we
have General Admissions so here's the
lineup Nashville January 12th
Indianapolis February 16th Austin
February 23rd Salt Lake City April 24th
in Anaheim May 2nd so head to
ramseysolutions.com and reserve your
seats right now while you can so I don't
know if you all have heard or not but
one of the things I hate anything that
rips you people off out there
I hate it and pretty much the people in
those businesses hate me
so if you sell whole life life insurance
you're probably not a Dave Ramsey fan
because I tell people that what you sell
is screwing them and they shouldn't do
it uh if you sell credit cards I tell
people not to use them if you sell car
leases I tell people it is the most
expensive way to operate a vehicle
because that's what my calculator and
smart Money Magazine agrees with me say
these are the things out there one of
the things we've told people not to do
for years and if you ever get stuck in
one of these dadgum near impossible to
get out is a freaking timeshare
don't go in the Tiger cage and that's
what it is if you go into one of these
I'm going to get a free weekend are you
that cheap I'm gonna get a free weekend
and my return is because I don't value
my dignity my pride or my time I'm going
to sit in a seven hour presentation on
uh what a timeshare is and um that's
going into the Tiger cage so you're
going in there you know the Tiger's
hungry you know he's not been fed
because that's pretty much a timeshare
salesman and you know you look like
fresh meat because you is
and so then you end up I know Dave but I
just couldn't I couldn't get away from
him and I signed it and and now I've got
a timeshare you got screwed it's
legalized fraud one lawyer says well
here this is coming out jury Awards over
one million dollars to consumers in
timeshare deception lawsuit against
fantasy Resorts okay now the name should
have got it I was gonna say don't ever
buy something called a-n-t-a-s-e-a
somebody sat down I was like you know it
would be a great idea to buy something
from this is like this is the worst of
trailer park redneck that's incredible
fantasy Resort it looks feels like a
billboard you see driving down the
highway screams we're gonna screw you
and you he just screams it right
it's called fantasy fantasy oh look
honey it's catchy let's we're gonna get
caught let's buy it a superior court
jury in New Jersey decided in favor of
consumers deceived by the time share
seller fantasy Resorts awarding the
plaintiffs 1 million 69 285 for the
Atlantic City resorts intentionally
deceptive sales practices which is the
only ones they have the jury agreed that
fantasies tactics left consumers
with timeshare purchases they couldn't
use as described no you're kidding I can
imagine their attorney just what got up
in front of the judge and Jerry and said
guys we called it fantasy come on right
there says it I mean can you not it's
just like of course we're gonna rip you
off with payments and Rising maintenance
fees they couldn't escape fantasy
attacked the deck against these families
stack the deck against these families
from the start so the attorney uh were
grateful for the jury's hard work and
willingness to hold them accountable in
trial fantasy it minted to making
knowingly false statements in to lure
potential buyers into binding timeshare
sales agreements through a process that
violated the New Jersey real estate
timeshare act Rita
so Rita didn't like fantasy
[Music]
I'm not going to say it but there's
something going through my head right
now okay me too
let's keep moving on us that's funny
it's funny but it'll get us thrown off
the air all right also misled consumer
plaintiffs into believing that their
purchase was a real estate investment oh
my God okay how do you how
where have you been living which cave
which rock are you under if you don't
understand timeshares are an absolute
screw job by now do not buy them under
any circumstances in any setting for
what you pay for them you could buy a
freaking hotel by the time you're
through and you can't get out of them
they're dead come near impossible to get
away from them you can't sell them
nobody wants them because nobody's dumb
enough to buy them except you
so stop it stop it stop it stop it if
you ever have to buy something you think
am I about to get screwed and the name
of the company is fantasy the answer is
yes probably
I think so I think so I I've been
trashing timeshare companies for years
I've never seen this company name before
today no this is classic it's like it's
like a beverage in the ocean together
it's just the worst all right let's get
serious and try to help some real people
all right moving on Lloyd is with us in
Charleston South Carolina Hey Lloyd
what's up
hey Mr Dave hey Dr Delaney how y'all
doing today great how can we help
Yeah so basically I lost my mom earlier
this year
um and she left some money to me and my
siblings and substantial amount around
45
000 and I have a younger brother that is
an addict and I'm really just trying to
figure out what I can do you know
legally to keep him from getting that in
his hands right away and try to spread
it out possibly or because I'm worried
I'll just lose him
um you know either this year or next
year whenever this money comes and we've
already lost three family members this
year so how old is
he is 27. what's he addicted to
um
heroin
tough one thanks man did he have a rough
go of it as a kid
um no
I've known my dad uh both kind of got
caught in it together and I lost my dad
two weeks before I lost my mom okay do
it you left him you lost him to heroin
my dad yep yo dude two weeks before my
mom died
man I'm sorry dude that's a lot of loss
um I'm assuming uh you guys have sat
down with little brother and had
interventions and walked him through and
tried to get care for him and all that
yeah my mom sent them to like three
different facilities over the past eight
years and who's the executor of the
estate
so my mom didn't have a will
um because you know she she took her own
life and my stepdad is the one that's
kind of handling everything she died
your mom died by Suicide
yeah good night what a mess
childhood was chaos huh
yeah I mean it's been a crazy year yeah
it's been a crazy life it's been a crazy
long couple years man I'm so sorry
brother
so sorry
um legally there's nothing you can do
unless the court makes a ruling as to
his competency
if they rule him as incompetent then
whatever now your father-in-law has been
appointed the executor and by the
probate courts I assume or will be
appointed that
um I if I were him I would go before the
judge and tell the judge your problem
and see if the judge will do anything to
tie up this money and he actually might
giving this is one of those rare
situations there's enough stuff that's
happening it's going to be a mental
illness and addiction in your family he
just might yeah that he can look around
and go look we've you know Dad dies of
this mom dies with suicide kids 27 he's
been in and out of rehab this might be
the death blow for him and
[Music]
the other route to go is much more
expensive and harder and that is to go
before the circuit court and have him
declared mentally incompetent to take
care of himself therefore he can't
manage any assets and you keep
everything away from him
that's a big responsibility you're
taking on when you do that too this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
thank you
welcome to the Ramsey Show Dr John
deloney Ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five
you jump in and we'll talk so John I
want to Circle back on that last call
for just a second
um because I've gotten that call over
the 30 years
or some version of it many times my
my sibling is addicted or my sibling is
irresponsible
and they're getting ready to receive an
inheritance
how can I keep them from getting it
basically uh and doing harm to
themselves or at a minimum squandering
the money
um I get that call a lot and I think
this is one of those
um
you got to get Upstream things
absolutely you know if if there's if you
keep jumping in the river and saving
drowning children you eventually need to
stop doing that and go upstream and see
who's throwing the kids into the lake
that's right throw them who's throwing
them in the river why are they coming
down drowning you gotta you gotta get
upstream and stop the problem at its
core pull it out by the roots
um and it's too late
to do that when there's an inheritance
on the way because someone has just
passed away now that one was
particularly tragic right that just
called but um uh the the only thing that
you out there can do is do an estate
plan and don't put people in it that are
irresponsible uh you're not when you
give someone money when something when
someone gets money whether it's given to
them or whether it's earned
it me included you include it magnifies
Who You Are
money doesn't make people evil it
reveals that they're evil money doesn't
make people good and generous it reveals
that they're good and generous
it magnifies Who You Are
that's what money does and sometimes
people get confused and they think well
you know the Bible says that money is
the root of all evil no it doesn't it
says the love
of money is the root of all evil and
there's lots of warnings in scripture
about wealth because it magnifies who
you are and so yeah if you've got
someone who's misbehaving and they get
money from an inheritance it's going to
magnify their misbehavior so you as a
parent you as a grandparent are not
blessing them your funding their
misbehavior I think it's where I think
it's worse I think you're cursing them
yeah you are providing them with
gasoline on a fire that they have lost
control of at this time and I'm not I'm
not even throwing grenades at someone
who's lost control this young man that
we just talked to mom dies by Suicide
dad introduces him to heroin at a young
age
um I'm not gonna hate that kid for
having a drug problem he's man the two
people are supposed to love and protect
him dragged him right through the middle
of it but to hand that kid a blank check
is to say hey your life's out of control
it's on fire here's some gasoline and
it's it's
um obviously that situation is different
but if you think you are loving your
kids by not having a hard conversation
by not saying
not doing the hard thing of getting a
will man you're just
Dave and I just see the other side of it
man and it's these kids to get these
checks and are these adults that are now
that formerly kids are now adults to get
these checks and it's just Madness it's
just Madness and if you're the if you're
the sibling
and you're the you're not the prodigal
son you're the prodigal son's older
brother
check yourself too because it's real
easy to be like well I followed all the
rules and I did everything right and I
don't want them getting the money
because they've always been the Sass or
they left town or they
man your parents get to do with their
parents money what your parents are
going to do with your parents money
right you know and and here's you really
can't legally
uh keep someone from being stupid you're
asking the course stupid it's not
illegal we don't have prisons that large
you're asking you're asking the courts
to take away somebody's civil rights and
that's a high bar yeah that's a really
high bar you've got to prove medically
beyond a shadow of a doubt Cody's in
Charlotte North Carolina hey Cody what's
up
oh not much hope everybody's doing well
thanks for taking the call sure man how
can we help
you got a quick question so I'm an
electrical designer in Charlotte North
Carolina where construction especially
in the multi-family business is
outrageously busy right now
um my company is a small company we are
always in need of more electrical
designers but there's nobody applying to
the job
my company has treated me well it's the
first company I've ever worked for I've
been here seven and a half years now
they have offered me a
kind of a private deal it's a
supplemental executive retirement plan
which I didn't even know existed until a
couple months ago
um they are pretty much saying you know
if you stay for this certain amount of
time we'll give you a lot sum of money
um
one of the hardest working people here
working way more than I should there are
other companies that are trying to hire
me pretty much knocking my doors down
and being a loyal person that
would never dream of leaving outside of
the reason of a terrible work-life
balance and just overall a lot of stress
um just wanted to get everybody's
opinion on on what what my next approach
should be
I Dave challenged me on this pushback on
me if I'm wrong here
um Cody I always
I always want to know why I will be
worth that money in five years and I'm
not now
um exactly if I'm worth extra dollars
then what you're trying to do is you're
trying to buy my inability to move
and as a business owner as a guy who's
LED
um a number of teams I want to make the
the life of my teammates so good that
they have to think hard about leaving I
don't want them to I don't want to own
them and so they're Shackled to me for
the next four years that just seems
backwards to me I'd rather pay really
well right now and
like Dave has done for me encourage me
hey go home because we're playing a long
game here
um I have a tendency to overwork like
you do and just keep riding and grinding
and grinding
um it's I also have a tendency to burn
myself out and so I I
this is your first job I remember that
loyalty that hey you hired me so I have
to give you my soul
um my gut says man it's time for you to
go Dave what do you think how old are
you
I'm 27. I'm about to be 28 next month
how many people in The Firm
uh 14. it started with seven
um I was one of so many of them are
older than you double
um everybody except for two okay
and you've been there five years
seven and a half seven and a half years
okay all right yes all right
um I've been there since I was a young
grasshopper yeah okay
well here's the thing you're an engineer
so yes by definition you're a detail guy
uh so uh 100 of the systems that you
involve yourself in will not work your
satisfaction
correct that includes your marriage
parenting everything
because you're a detail guy okay and
you're a real follower and uh that's
where this Duty and loyalty comes from
as well and so um that's an admirable
quality uh I think what you need to do
is you need to say what circumstances
would cause me to want to stay here a
check five years from now is not one of
them uh a reasonable number of hours is
one of them and I think maybe you um you
know I I usually just have an old Pastor
that every time I when I first became a
Christian I would go into his office and
I would complain about stuff at the
church and he'd make me head of the
committee to fix it and um I looked up
and I was on 10 committees before I
figured out his system and so um yeah so
maybe you start working on leadership
skills and start talking to the team to
the owners about moving uh and taking
over some of these areas that are a hot
mess and maybe you can clean them up and
maybe you get paid for that also and
then maybe we work you know 40 or 50
hours and not 80 or 90. and so under
those two circumstances I would stay
if I could have some influence on the
systems that are broken and if I can get
a reasonable number of hours to work I
would stay
those are deal breakers for me if I'm in
your shoes and I'm ready to go if
they're not willing to fix the hot mess
I can't stand looking this hot mess
anymore I've done reached the end of my
patience with it and um I've either got
to help you fix it or I got to leave it
to you one of the two and that's when
it's time to go that's what I would do
amen thanks for calling in
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
our scripture of the day habakkuk 2-2
write the vision make it plain on
tablets
so he may run who reads it
Jordan Peterson said don't underestimate
the power of vision and Direction these
are irresistible forces able to
transform what might appear to be
unconquerable unconquerable obstacles
into traversable Pathways and expanding
opportunities oh my God Jordan all right
let me try it again I don't even know
what it says all right don't
underestimate the power of vision and
Direction okay
these are vision and direction are
irresistible forces yes able to
transform yes what might appear to be
unconquerable conquerable objects
obstacles
into traversable Pathways and expanding
opportunities he sounds like a college
professor in Diaz yeah um so all right I
love Jordan and I I I mean I like a lot
of what he says obviously he's a very
polarizing character people get really
really pissed off we booked him to speak
at uh our entree Leadership Summit this
year he's one of our speakers coming up
in May and a number of people are highly
excited that he's coming in another
number of people are highly pissed off
that he's coming I can't believe Dave
Ramsey Associated himself with a with
what
I mean just because you don't like what
he says oh well listen I don't do cancel
culture just don't go it's okay you know
don't listen to the show and now we were
out in Sacramento the other day and they
called and said I didn't want Dr John
deloney on his on Jordan's podcast so
um we we hung around a little while and
you got to go over and do the podcast
and hang out and uh that'll be airing in
a few weeks and
um you know you got people mad at you
lose you're losing Instagram followers
oh darn yeah I don't know I don't know
how you're gonna make it
um but uh we'll let you guys know when
that air is airing because I would love
to hear the conversation between you two
I bet it was fabulous it was just it was
too nerds trying to figure it out right
and uh he's a he was extremely
hospitable very very kind and
um yeah I think we had a great
discussion on on 50 different topics
which he is he's known for and
um was gracious I don't listen to his
podcast all the time but I've listened
to three or four different ones when
certain people were on that I love then
I listened to him on Rogan yeah and
that's a fascinating discussion yeah
those long form you know two hour
interviews and that kind of stuff
fascinating and we spent two hours
together what he's really good at is
taking an idea
and this sounds good on on the table and
he'll run it all the way to the ends of
that idea and see if it's still holds
the unintended consequence that's right
and um if it holds he'll Circle back and
say you were right and I wasn't and if
it doesn't hold he'll let you know yeah
critical thinking skills are more than
just the end of the week yeah but I
think what he does that's a gift is he
talks he I tell somebody think
critically but I don't show you how to
do that and if you'll hang with him long
enough he'll walk you through here's the
critical thinking process here's where
this ends and ends in ashes or it ends
in like you said you go get over these
obstacles and things work out great for
you so it's it's really a like uh
sitting down with an HVAC guy who's
walking you through how to wire this
thing together that's what he's doing
except with how to think no very
interesting Yeah Austin Is With Us
Austin is in Amarillo Austin welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hey thank you so much for having me guys
I really appreciate it sure what's up
all right um first I just want to say
I'm I'm really looking forward to that
podcast episode I will definitely be
tuning into it and then um yeah yeah
absolutely and then so just to start um
so I'm so new to everything Finance
which is a terrible thing to say because
I'm 28 years old but um my wife and I
have been married for seven years and I
actually just got a better job making uh
quite a bit more money than I have in
the past we have two credit cards with
credit card debt on them we have our car
payment we also have our house payments
I just want to know what I can do to
like get us out of debt as soon as
possible and do it right and get her on
board with everything because I'm so new
to all this and but I'm loving it I've
been listening to the GL show for for
weeks now and I'm listening to a Total
Money Makeover the audiobook right now
and it's just been completely inspiring
and just trying to do whatever I can to
get out of debt and not be stupid like I
almost did today and buy a motorcycle so
no I just absolutely don't want to do
that so yeah so what are you making now
um so total for my wife and I together
we're making around 91 before taxes good
for you
well thank you very much yeah I'm very
grateful it's a bless excellent
excellent okay well you've seen the baby
steps in Total Money Makeover and if
you've been listening three or four
weeks you've heard us talk about you
know stop everything until you got a
thousand dollars anything above a
thousand dollars you have not counting
retirement uh we're gonna dump it on the
next step maybe step two and list all
your debts your car payments your credit
cards your student loans whatever
smallest to largest we're going to
attack them in that order paying minimum
payments on everything but the little
one you've seen all that haven't you
yes sir yeah I have yeah so that's
that's the system that's the process to
follow and it is fairly straightforward
and simple there's some nuances to it
that people call and want to know about
from time to time or know if they're
most often they want to know if they're
the exception and the answer is no
um so this is the system it works 10
million people have done it and um as
far as getting her on board
um I need you need to know that uh
you're a few weeks ahead of her in
consuming this information so you're a
few weeks ahead of her with your
newfound excitement for the subject
so don't expect her to be at the same
level of excitement that you have
because she doesn't have the same
information you've got so how do we
solve that well you start sharing with
her hey here's what I'm reading and this
is getting me excited here's why I'm
excited I think we could live with no
payments and I think we would become
wealthy if we did that and I think we
could travel more and be more generous
and uh fund our kids college and do a
bunch of high quality things if we would
get control of this area and clean it up
and I'd like for us to continue to talk
about this and learn about it and um you
know I I don't and I and I don't want to
be in a situation where I'm like
preaching at you I want you to to learn
this stuff with me so here's the
audiobook here's the podcast give it a
listener you know I've had spouses that
said okay we're going on a weekend trip
and they listen to the podcast the whole
trip and trap their spouse in the car
and won't let them out and that kind of
stuff we you know that but then they
come back you know converted not by me
but by new information your brain Austin
can I tell you what um I'm a West Texas
guy I married a West Texas girl can I
tell you what I told my wife
absolutely man I'm all ears um I I sat
down and said I'm really scared
I've put our family in a position to
where we are not financially safe and we
are one mistake away and I played a huge
role in this and I'm scared would you
join me in doing something else and my
wife got choked up and she said I've
been waiting for this conversation for a
long time it would took me taking a knee
and
um you're gonna have to be there in
Amarillo and you're gonna have to not
buy motorcycles and you're gonna have to
not lift your truck any higher than it
already is it's too high already you're
gonna have to not eat all that barbecue
and you're gonna have to just get after
it and you'll have a group of people
that think you're nuts and you're not
being a true Texan and there's going to
be other people that wink at you and
they nod and those are usually the
ranchers and they know what a life is
with no debt and they're gonna say go
get them buddy right and you're gonna
wake up let me let me tell you on the
other end of this thing it is like
nothing you can imagine
the freedom right it's just it's just
like freed on it yeah I definitely want
that I want to not have the stress of
just finances anymore like you know the
feeling of drowning I really don't want
to have that anymore like the feeling of
being afraid of just going out and
spending any money on any food like you
know it's like I don't want to have that
feeling anymore so yeah so I used to
work for a guy that was um he was in the
process of building his wealth and he I
said what's your goal and he goes I want
to have enough money that I can read the
menu left to right
instead of starting with the price I get
to just pick out what I want and then
look at the price
I don't know how much money that is but
that's a that's a good that's a good
goal I like that goal Sharon Ramsey's
goal was we were so dead gun broke and
bankrupt and lost as a ball and Tall
weed so her goal was I want to go to the
grocery store and buy anything I want
fill up two buggies I want to be able to
not say no at the grocery store and I'm
like that's really not that much money I
mean I think we can get there on that
one mine was Dave i j all I wanted I was
so desperate for was one night of sleep
I just went to sleep and you hear me
talk about that a lot and it's because
that
I didn't sleep for so long and I thought
it was this I thought it was this
thought it was this and it wasn't it was
this six-figure debt that was just
hounding me man it was hounding me
hounding me hounded Financial Peace
that's real it's real hey hang on
brother we'll sign you guys up for
Financial Peace University you and your
wife go through that together if you'll
go through the class together I 100
guarantee you you will do this stuff if
you do it together it'll work and you'll
both be on the same page and we're
really good in financial face University
by getting everybody to do it once
you're in there but you gotta plug in
you got to do it but we'll give it to
you as a gift and get you guys started
thank you for calling in that puts us
out of the Ramsey Show in the books
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
hey it's John deloney co-host of the
Ramsey show did you know over 18
[Music]
Miss show every week a lot of those
people listen on one of our 600 plus
radio stations across the country to
find a station near you go to
ramseysolutions.com show
[Music]